we just got all of the brand new iphones
but today we are going to focus on the
brand new 13 pro max and compare it to
the 12 pro max but cover things that all
the other reviewers didn't talk about
such as the display differences speaker
loudness and quality magsafe magnet
strength 5g data speeds charging wattage
display dimming and overheating gaming
performance and more my biggest concern
with this new 13 pro max is the weight
they made this thing much heavier it got
a little bit thicker so let's see how it
is in the hand let me peel this off
right away
and do i really notice it not that much
surprisingly yeah it's a little bit
heavier but i've actually been wearing a
case a slim case for the last week or so
and maybe that helps but um it's really
not that bad it's a little bit
noticeable but not too different let's
take a look at the back here we have the
brand new blue color here and personally
i'm not that big of a fan of it but take
a look at that camera bump we already
had a huge one with the 12 pro max this
thing is massive now we will do some
camera tests in this video but we are
going to be working on an ultimate
comparison not only testing out the new
13 pro max also against the 12 for max
but the 11 pro max as well so if you
guys want to see all of the differences
going back even to the older one make
sure you guys hit that subscribe button
and enable those notifications not only
are the lenses themselves quite a bit
larger and the whole glass is larger if
we take a look from the side
everything is much deeper as well these
are some massive lenses meaning that the
sensors are also quite a bit larger so
let's take a look at this we have some
wobble oh look at that that is extreme i
remember when he complained about a
little bit of wobble this is getting
crazy interestingly all of the buttons
are slightly higher including the sim
card so you definitely cannot reuse your
old case from your previous 12 pro max
you have to get a new one let's get this
phone turned on and we will compare the
new notch but first i do want to mention
charging bricks of course apple is not
including one so if you want to buy one
i would get this anchor they are not a
sponsor of the channel but this thing is
only 11 12 bucks and it has a flip out
prong as well so it's much smaller than
apples and it's less expensive as well
but with that there's something that
apple is not telling you something that
i mentioned in my previous video and
that is the fact that this thing can
actually accept more wattage than 20
watts so we will be testing that in just
a little bit and take a look at that
that new notch is significantly smaller
it's a bigger difference in real life
than what you see online now another
thing that i noticed is that the speaker
is now at the top touching the frame
instead of having a cutout in the
display itself and with that the camera
has been moved to the left side from the
right hand side so if you're taking a
selfie make sure you switch where you
look at overall that is a pretty
significant difference that they made
and with that you might be able to
notice that is a little bit deeper as
well so it did get a little bit taller
but overall this is definitely a welcome
upgrade and i hope that the software
catches up and we can use that space i'm
really curious if the angles have
changed with these new sensors for face
id unlock we will test that in just a
bit but as i'm setting this up oh my
goodness it is extremely smooth it also
seems like apple changed um the
animation speed everything seems to be
very snappy not only that refresh rate
but also just how quick everything's
happening the next thing that i'm really
curious about is magsafe apple did not
mention that they got any better but we
had lots of leaks and rumors so let's go
ahead and test it out what if they did
put in stronger magnets so right here
the maxis i'm used to uh it's really
easy to pull up wallets pull off pretty
easily now let's test out the 13 pro max
ah
it's aligning pretty well but the force
that it's required to pull up
not much different let's give the new
wallet a shot maybe they increase the
magnets in there
nope same old easy to twist not that
strong so that definitely is a
disappointment but of course apple
didn't advertise that one huge
difference that we do have is the new
pro motion 120 hertz display and along
with the faster refresh rate it almost
seems like they made the animation
smoother some of the stuff that i'm
switching going into different settings
seems really quick as you can see with
the slow motion footage this is
definitely noticeable and it's a really
good improvement from before not only
does this make everything much smoother
but it also can drop down all the way to
10 hertz and that ends up saving you
battery life so it's a win-win in either
way now one thing you guys should know
that if you're somebody who likes to use
the low power mode when you enable that
that will actually limit it to 60 hertz
but it still will drop down to 10 and
you can also toggle this in
accessibility so with the new batteries
and we'll talk about battery life in
just a bit this is a huge update apple
said that the 13 pro's new display is
now brighter up to a thousand nits so
let's compare that i have my 12 pro max
maxed out here and i adjusted the top
camera to expose for the screens here we
go with
using manual brightness and to me
they look exactly the same so it looks
like if you're manually adjusting it
you're not gonna get any difference
let's go ahead and turn auto brightness
back on and let's head outside and see
if the new one gets brighter looking at
both side by side you can tell that the
13 pro max is brighter it's not a huge
difference but it is noticeable and
interesting now that i'm back inside you
could see that just with auto brightness
enabled the new one does choose to be
brighter by default and now for
something that i'm really excited for
the speakers apple didn't mention that
it got better but every year they're
making some improvements so let's go
ahead and take a listen
[Music]
now
[Music]
wow guys did you hear that difference i
was expecting it to get a little bit
better but not that big of a difference
that is a lot louder and i'm surprised
because they move this speaker they made
that notch smaller
but this thing not only sounds better it
sounds richer it's quite a bit louder as
well and that gets me excited to compare
to the s21 ultra we're gonna do that
video soon because those speakers are
really good and they blew away the 12
pro max so if you guys want to see that
video hit that subscribe button down
below and with that you can help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
we would definitely appreciate it and
now let's get into performance and we're
not only going to do the standard
benchmarks we are going to make this
interesting we are going to start out
with geekbench 5 though as you guys
could see we're going from 2.99
gigahertz up to 3.23 that is a very high
clock speed both have six gigs of ram
let's go ahead and run the cpu benchmark
all right we have our results and it
looks like the difference isn't that big
in single core we got a 10 gain pretty
much matching up or even slightly
beating the m1 which is crazy in
multi-core without a 15 percent
improvement in performance now usually
iphones are
larger than that as far as the
difference but of course in cpu terms
that is pretty good but what i'm more
interested in is the graphics
performance so let's go ahead and run
the compute test of course this is the
first iphone that has a 5 core gpu and
the regular 13 or 13 mini has a 4 core
that's been updated so here we should
see a huge improvement take a look at
that guys we have 9 383
compared to 14 146 and this is
battling against top of the line
ultrabooks with intel i7s crazy
performance that's actually slightly
more than 50 percent higher performance
and actually uses slightly less wattage
to achieve that score that is incredible
now we are going to do a couple more
graphics tests we're going to do 3d mark
we're going to do n2 to see if we get
any dimming but first what i want to do
is test out the ssd or the storage that
is in here both of these are
128 gig models here all right guys we
have some really weird results here
first off let's take a look at both
models the 12 for max and 13 pro max
that have 128 gigs here as far as the
read speed looks like my 12 pro max is
faster at 1200 compared to 930 but on
the right speed this thing is going up
to 1219
compared to 88 now this number seemed
really weird and that's probably because
my storage is almost full so vadim
actually got his phone out and it looks
like his 12 pro max that also is 128 gig
the read speed similar but the write
speeds about 500 just under that so this
shows us that the new 13 pro max same
storage size the right speed is a lot
faster than it was before more than
twice as fast but along with that he
also has his new 13 pro max that has a
256 gig storage in here look at these
speeds guys right speed 1254 about the
same but the read is almost at 1600
so it looks like if you buy the base
model 12 pro with 128 you actually go
down in storage speeds compared to last
year but if you opt for the 256 one or
larger you have a huge boost so that
will help apps load quite a bit quicker
all right guys before we dig deep into
graphics performance thermal throttling
screen gaming i want to do a 5g speed
test now there is a new modem in this
device apple didn't give us much info so
let's see how they compare both these
are on the same network connect the same
server both have two bars out of four so
let's go ahead and test out the speed
jeez that is a lot slower
on the 13 pro somehow finish the
download first
that is weird but the speeds are a lot
lower
same thing is going for the upload i
don't know what is going on you know
what let me go ahead and cut this out
let's do these one by one maybe the 12
for max is just sucking all the data for
itself so let's run the 13 pro max first
we're looking at 38 down and 39 up now
the 12 pro max and the 12 pro max got 86
down but 26 uploads so it got slower
there that is still a pretty big
difference um now let me go outside
we'll do both these tests not inside a
concrete room all right guys so this
isn't a fluke we ran this multiple times
outside we ran them both at the same
time and then separately and the 12 pro
max is consistently getting faster
download speeds and here it was actually
slightly faster for both now this is
something that concerns you make sure
you guys are subscribed because in
vadim's review video which is going to
be amazing he will test it out in a
couple parts probably in his basement
and see if this is consistent in
different parts not just here where our
office is located alright guys this is
about to get interesting we are going to
push these phones to their limits but
first i want to take a look at thermals
before we get into it these phones have
been resting for about 10 minutes we've
been transferring footage and look at
the 12 pro max at the left it has this
hot spot at the bottom that is much
hotter than everything else whereas the
13 pro max is much cooler all around i
don't know what that spot is but i guess
we will find out now my biggest
complaint about my 12 pro max is the
screen dimming when you're gaming when
it gets hot when you're outside so we're
going to see if it got any better i have
antutu opened up right here and i maxed
out the screens which if you're outside
you kind of need to do that so this is a
torture scenario let's see if this dims
and also how hot they get and it looks
like right away we're getting a bunch of
heat at the top left of the phones the
13 pro max is hitting 95 degrees
fahrenheit
and we're getting a hundred
on the 12 pro max and did you guys just
see that both of them dimmed at the same
time now that is weird that they pretty
much maxed out maxed out there because
this one is running about five degrees
fahrenheit cooler and bam did you guys
see that right there the 12 for max
dimmed even more while the 13 pro max is
staying
right where it was after the first
dimming so this is probably roughly
about 80 percent brightness compared to
here probably about 50. that is a huge
difference guys you guys see that right
there this is unplayable outdoors
this is still playable and that was just
so frustrating to me especially when i
was doing things like flying my drone i
ended up crashing because of screen
dimming let's take another look at
thermals i switched to celsius this time
that's what we should have been at 38
degrees celsius on the 13 pro max and 40
on the 12 pro max so even though it
dimmed it is still running much hotter
of course the 13 pro max also has a new
display that is more energy efficient
let's check what the brightnesses are
actually here so here let's see we're
going down
all right so that's roughly what 80 or
so like i was guessing
80 is where we're maxing out at above
that it doesn't change and on this one
we're going we're going we're going all
right there you go
that's where we're starting to get
capped at that's about 35
that's not even 50 where it's capped
and it is still sitting there it's
probably been about three minutes or so
since we got done with the graphics it's
still running so hot we're this one yeah
we're still capped at about 80 thank you
apple for solving my biggest complaint
bam guys we have a result and right
there when we got a result did you guys
see how this one just went back to max
brightness whereas the 12 pro max it is
still trying to recover and it's still
sitting there at that 35
or so brightness level
that is just incredible and then taking
a look at the overall scores i mean i'm
sorry guys you have to look at that
brightness let me actually turn this
down because it's blowing out that
camera let's get it lower now we have a
28 and a half percent difference in
performance when we take into account
the cpu the graphics the memory that
memory scores a lot higher here and the
ui score all right guys and now let's
see the performance differences between
the graphics as you guys could see both
of them have cooled down they're at the
same exact temperature and i went ahead
and i set the brightness to 80 percent
to keep it fair because most people are
not going to play with brightness maxed
out we're going to run the 3d mark
wildlife extreme unlimited mode which is
4k so it's a ton of graphics that are
running and we have our results we have
15.8 frames per second compared to 12.5
that is about 27 percent better graphics
performance and it's interesting that
it's not at that 50 percent better as we
saw with the metal test a lot lower here
but of course this is pushing these
phones crazy hard with 4k now what i
want to do next is go into the settings
i'm going to go ahead and turn on low
power mode
which will use less power and what's
interesting is that the 13 pro max even
though has five graphics cores in this
mode it will only use 3.2 watts compared
to 3.5 watts for the four graphics cores
in the 12 pro max and this will save
battery life for you and at the same
time it's gonna reduce screen dimming
and have less heat let's hit start and
we'll see what kind of performance we
get with a lot less power usage and here
we have the results stick with me i'll
explain why this matters here we have 12
frames per second compared to 12.3 so in
low power mode it seems like
the 12 pro max barely changes from 12.5
down to 12.3
but the 13 pro max drops quite quite a
bit but when we're running this way the
13 pro max actually uses 22 percent less
graphics power and it only gets four
percent less frames per second now i've
never thought about using low power mode
for gaming but if you want to save
battery or you want to minimize screen
dimming this is a perfect mode and now
you can still get fantastic performance
more than enough for every game even
gentian impact in low power mode but you
will be saving a lot of battery and not
dealing with overheating issues let's
run antutu one more time and we will see
the difference as far as screen dimming
it's really interesting that in this
test antutu
in low power mode it's actually smoother
with the 13 pro max
even though the fps was lower
in our 3d mark we just ran antutu and
this is interesting first off the
graphics performance there were three
different tests we actually have about
30 better performance here in low power
mode on both so we're seeing actually a
good difference when we're not capping
to anything and then overall
the 13 pro max in low power mode is
almost as fast as a 12 pro max was in
regular mode we actually have just uh
less less than five percent performance
difference so not only do you have a
better bigger battery if you really need
to save battery life you will still get
super good performance super smooth
performance while being in that low
power mode and now let's talk about
battery of course i like i mentioned the
13 pro max has a much larger battery
it's about 18 larger and through these
tests you'll see that we're actually now
at 45 percent charge on the 13 per max
compared to 39 but when we started the
12 hour max was at 75 compared to 70 so
those percentages have flip-flopped and
now what i want to do is test out
charging performance apple didn't
mention that it got any better but we
have heard that the 13 pro max can
accept much higher wattage now as you
can see our 12 per max is using 20 watts
of power with this meter when it's at
around 39
charge and let's go ahead and unplug it
we'll plug in the new 13 pro max
and it looks like the 13 pro max is
charging at 23.39
watts when it's at 45
now it could actually hit a peak of 27
watts when you're closer to zero
compared to 23 with a 12 pro max so if
you're somebody that needs to buy a
charger we would recommend buying a 30
watt charger if you want the maximum
performance and keep in mind the battery
is larger so it takes longer to charge
as well and we'll go ahead and leave a
link with our suggested chargers down in
the video description below and now
let's talk about the cameras apple spent
so much time talking about them and in
this video we're going to cover a few
things the biggest changes and then
along with that we are gonna do a blind
camera comparison against the s21 ultra
which is gonna be extremely fun that's
21 got really good and i'm gonna compare
the 13 pro max against the 12 pro max
and the 11 pro max we're gonna go back
one more generation you guys don't want
to miss out on that so make sure you
guys are subscribed but let's take a
look at the differences as far as the
selfie cam nothing changed but we do
have that new cinematic mode so as you
guys can see we have some blur where on
the
12 pro max you cannot do that only for
photos not video and then on the back we
also have that cinematic mode less
tested out i'm using tap to focus here
to switch from vadim to this little bush
tree thing and that is a very tough
subject of course we're gonna have to
look at this in detail but that is so
cool to have that and you can also take
it off later which you can't do with the
samsungs and we have the new three times
zoom lens so here's the difference
comparing the 2.5 times zoom on the 12
pro max and here is the macro mode so
we're in the ultra wide
and dang i'm surprised by how smoothly
that changes focus
okay geez louise look at that that is
crazy close
let's go ahead and go to this little
bush here
whoa we're like right in there
that is insane and very smooth when
we're changing focus so all of these
lenses and sensors were updated other
than the front-facing ones so the ultra
wide let's in a lot more light here's a
sample image of that so we are going to
have to spend a ton of time making some
very detailed very interesting camera
comparisons for you guys looking at
photo and video so overall what are my
thoughts well first off i do notice the
weight more so especially when i switch
hands holding it with my left hand you
definitely notice it but it is a really
good upgrade a lot of people are calling
it the iphone 12s
but if the iphone 12s gives us much
better battery life better performance
hertz display definitely less dimming
better cameras i'm all up for it so if
you're somebody that has this phone is
it worth upgrading
well i think if you care about pro
features you care about good cameras
care about battery life yes and if you
have an older phone the 11 the 10s the
10 you're gonna notice a huge difference
upgrading to the 13 pro max so thank you
guys for watching once again you guys
can subscribe right over there you guys
can help us reach our goal of a million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right there that's been max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]